hello everyone welcome to part two of
our series of screencasts on distributed
word representations the focus of this
screencast will be on matrix designs
let's start with the word by word design
that we concentrated on in part one uh
so here again we have our vocabulary
along the rows that same vocabulary is
repeated along the columns and the cell
values capture the number of times that
each row word co-occurred with each
column word in some large collection of
texts
this matrix will have two properties
that i think make it noteworthy for
developing semantic representations the
first is it will be very dense and as we
bring in more data from ever larger
corporate will get denser and denser in
virtue of the fact that more words will
tend to co-occur with more other words
in these this ever larger collection of
documents
the second is that it kind of has the
nice property that its dimensionality
will remain fixed even as we bring in
more data as long as we decide on the
vocabulary ahead of time all we'll be
doing is incrementing individual cell
values and so we can bring in as much
data as we want without changing the
fundamental design of the object
both of those other things are points of
contrast with another common design that
you see in the literature especially in
information retrieval and that is the
word by document design
for this design again i have words along
the rows but my columns are now
individual documents and the cell values
capture the number of times that each
word occurs in each one of those
documents
as you can imagine this is a very sparse
matrix in contrast to the word by word
one that we just looked at in virtue of
the fact that most words don't appear in
most documents
it will also have the property that as
we bring in more data in the form of
more documents
the shape of the matrix will change
we'll be adding column dimensions for
each new document that we bring into the
space and that could really affect the
kind of complications that we can do the
only thing that balances against the
ever increasing size of this matrix is
that because it is so sparse we might
have some easy and efficient ways of
storing it efficiently putting it on par
with a much more compact but dense word
by word matrix that i showed you before
now those are two very common designs
that you see in the literature but i
want you to think creatively and kind of
align your matrix design with it at
whatever problem you're trying to solve
so let me show you one that's really
radically different
this is what i've called the word by
discourse context matrix
i derived this from the switchboard
dialogue act corpus which is the
switchboard corpus where each dialogue
act has been annotated by an expert
annotator with the sort of dialogue act
or speech act that was performed by that
utterance
what that allows us to do is collect
a matrix where the rows are again words
but the columns are those individual
labels that annotators assigned i think
this is a really interesting matrix i
think if you appear even at this small
fragment you can see some interesting
information emerging so for example
absolutely occurs a lot in acceptance
dialogue acts whereas more hedged words
like actually in any way are more common
in things like rejecting part of a
previous utterance and i'm sure there
are lots of other interesting patterns
in this matrix
and of course that's just a glimpse of
the many other design choices that you
could make again think creatively you
could have something like adjective by
modified noun this would probably
capture some very local syntactic
information or collocational information
we could generalize that a bit to word
by syntactic context to explicitly try
to model how words associate with
specific syntactic structures
be very different from our usual
semantic goals for this course
word by search query might be a design
that you use information retrieval we
don't even have to limit this to
linguistic objects word by person could
capture the number of times that each
person
purchased a specific set of products and
then we could cluster people or products
on that basis
we could also mix linguistic and
non-linguistic things so word by person
might capture different usage patterns
for individual speakers and again again
allow us to doing some kind of
interesting clustering of words or of
people
we could also break out of two
dimensions we could have something like
word by word by pattern or verb by
subject by object many of the methods
that we cover in this unit are easily
generalized to more than two dimensions
so you could have that in mind and of
course as i said think creatively and
think in particular about how your
matrix design is aligned with whatever
modeling goal you have or whatever
hypothesis you're pursuing
another connection that i want to make
is that even though this feels like a
kind of modern idea in nlp
vector representations of words are
actually are of objects are actually
pervasive not only throughout machine
learning but also throughout science
right so think back to older modes of
nlp where we would write a lot of
feature functions we'll be exploring
such techniques they can be quite
powerful even though they feel very
different from the distributional
hypotheses that we've been pursuing in
fact they also represent individual data
points as vectors so for example given
the text like the movie was horrible i
might reduce that with my feature
functions to a vector that looks like
this and i might know as a human that
four captures the number of words
zero captures the number of proper names
and one over four captures the
percentage of negative words according
to some sentiment lexicon that's a human
level understanding of this in fact
those dimensions will acquire a meaning
to the extent that they assemble them
into a vector space model
and the column wise elements are
compared with each other
so even though the origins of the data
are very different in fact this is just
like
vector representations of words in the
way we've been discussing it the same
thing happens in experimental sciences
where you might have an experimental
subject come in and perform some act in
the lab they do a complicated physical
and human thing and you reduce it down
to a couple of numbers like a choice
they made or a reaction time and a
choice and so forth
we might model entire humans or entire
entire organisms with a vector of
numbers representing their physical
characteristics and perspectives and
outlooks and so forth again we might
know what these individual column
dimensions mean but they acquire a
meaning when we're doing modeling only
to the extent that they are embedded in
a matrix and can be compared to each
other across the columns
and so forth there are many other
examples of this where essentially
fundamentally all of our representations
are vector representations so maybe the
far out idea for this unit is just that
we can gather interesting vector
representations without all of the hand
built work that goes into the examples
on the slide right now
a final technical point a question that
you should ask that's kind of separate
from your particular
matrix design what is going to count as
co-occurrence so i think there are at
least two design choices that are really
important when answering this question
to illustrate them let's use this small
example so i have this text from swerve
of shore to bend of bay comma brings
and imagine that our focus word at our
particular point of analysis is this
token of the word two
and these indices here indicate going
left and right the distance by counts
from that particular focus word
the first question that you want to
decide is what your window of
co-occurrence is going to be so for
example if you set your window to 3
then the things that are within three
distance of your focus word will
co-occur with that word and everything
falling outside of that window will not
co-occur with that word according to
your analysis
if you make your window really big it
might encompass the entire document if
you make it very small it might
encompass only very local kind of
collocational information so you can bet
that that's going to be meaningful
there's a separate choice that you can
make falling under the heading of
scaling i think a default choice for
scaling is to just call it flat so what
you're saying there is something is
going to co-occur once with your focus
word if it's in the window that you've
specified and that would kind of equally
weight all of the things that are in the
window you could also decide to scale
them a common scaling pattern would be
one over n where n is the distance by
word from your focus word that would
have the effect that things occurred
that occur close to the word of interest
a co-occur with it more than things that
are at the edges that are near the end
of the window
those choices are going to have really
profound effects on the kinds of
representations that you develop here
are some generalizations i could offer
larger flatter windows will capture more
semantic information as the window gets
very large to encompass for example the
entire document you'll be capturing
essentially topical information in
contrast if you make your window very
small and scaled you'll tend to capture
more syntactic or collocational
information
independently of these choices you could
decide how text boundaries are going to
be involved so a text boundary at the
level of a sentence or a paragraph for a
document or a corpus could be a hard
boundary that's independent of your
window or you could decide that you're
going to allow your window to go across
different notions of segment that you
have that's really up to you and again i
think it will have major consequences
for downstream tasks involving the
representations that you've created
to help you begin exploring this space
the associated code released for this
course the associated notebooks provide
you with four word by word matrices they
have a few things that allow you to do
comparisons first there are two matrices
that were developed from the yelp
academic data set which is a lot of
reviews of products and services and
there are two matrices that come from
gigaword which is newswire text so
there's fundamentally a real difference
in the genre of text involved
in addition for each of those pairs of
corp
for each of those corpora we have two
different designs
window size of five and scaling of one
over n which ought to by my hypotheses
deliver a lot of kind of collocational
or syntactic information
and window size of 20 and scaling a flat
a very large window lots of things
co-occurring with lots of other things
that might be a better basis for
semantics and you have those two points
of variation both for yelp and for giga
word and i'm hoping that that kind of
gives you a sense for how these design
choices affect the representations that
you're able to develop
with methods that we're going to cover
in later parts of the screencast series